[Musique]
bienvenue dans ce nouveau numéro de paf
avec beaucoup de sujets abordés on va
parler de culture on va parler
l'université de grandes écoles
et puis peut-être dû vivre à saint
quentin qu'est ce que c'est 50 ah
qu'est-ce que ce sont les villes
nouvelles qu'elle ce qu'elles sont
devenues pour en parler parce qu'albi
dont jour je vous êtes ingénieur vous
êtes enseignant vous êtes bien qu'un
délégué de l'estaca qu'est l'école
supérieure des techniques aéronautiques
et de construction automobile avec
15/100 étudiante sur le site de sa
grandeur nous est depuis de 2015 se
serait il qu'un septembre 2015 exact en
2004 à des doubiens lbc par le directeur
des thermes de saint quentin en yvelines
de la scène nationale des états de saint
quentin en yvelines et le 5 juin
prochain
d'ailleurs ça sera diffusé en direct sur
cette chaîne vous allez annoncer le
programme complet presque complète
parler et puis je voudrais parce que
c'est une chose qui me fascine toujours
comment vous arrivez à autant de monde
avec des programmes souvent exigeants et
fois que je vous réponds tout de suite
c'est quand nous reçûmes est on est on
est quand même plusieurs le le théâtre
c'est une petite entreprise avec avec un
certain nombre de salariés
voilà on serait partis très largement le
travail puis on mise aussi nous on a un
travail de têtes chercheuses qui les
niches et qu'elles sont là qu'elles sont
des artistes aujourd'hui quels sont les
artistes de demain et je crois qu on
compte aussi beaucoup sur la fidélité à
ce lieu sur la confiance que nous font
les spectateurs et sur leur curiosité ça
c'est très important pour en parler
stéphane bancel
professeur à l'université de versailles
saint quentin on s'envoyait de la
facture on va parler avec vous peut-être
de bois de la jeunesse des étudiants
malaise s qui a parlé avec moi de la
jeunesse c'est marc est tout à fait
naturel à la crise j'en suis un digne
représentant sept lots représentant
plateau avec chivu s'est rajeuni chaque
jour chaque jour le jeu est un nouveau
jour la présidente de la fondation de
l'université de versailles saint rome de
muscu et vous êtes aussi le président du
coc des skis vous aurez 10 et 12 juin
prochain une assemblée qui peut guère
ouverte à tous justement un dense sur la
jeunesse sur la jeunesse alors peut-être
au bout commencer par ça est ce qu'il ya
un problème de la jeunesse dont
dans 50 s quels sont les problèmes font
qu'on rencontre saint quentin chacun va
plutôt bien mais effectivement dans le
bien il ya quelques points un peu moins
satisfaisants et le code éthique et donc
conseil de développement saint quentin
dans l'orbité de réaction et c'est ça
j'ai une assemblée composée d'habitants
demande du tissu associatif de
personnalités qualifiées comme lionel et
puis d'entrepreneurs qui a vocation à
réfléchir et apporter des avis aux élus
donc soit les élus nous saisit soit aux
saisies et donc on a travaillé sur le
projet de territoire de saint quentin
qui n'est pas encore adopté déjà par les
élus puis on a travaillé sur le plh i
c'est à dire le plan de l'habitat sur
saint quentin et surtout ces travaux on
s'est aperçu que il y avait une
difficulté sur la tranche des 18 30 ans
et justement on cherche un petit peu les
raisons parce que saint-quentin vieilli
ça c'est un godet stable et le seul flux
négatif c'est-à-dire le nombre
d'habitants qui diminue et laisser cette
tranche des 20 30 ans on aime bien qu'un
jour en dessous de 18 ans ils peuvent
pas s'enfuir mais ils sont chez papa
maman c'est à pas et est au dessus de 40
45 ans probablement reviennent t-il
parce que parce que malgré tout
l'habitat de saint quentin est agréable
de vivre à saint quentin c'est pas
désagréable et qui a de la culture il ya
plein de choses mais les 18 30 ans s'en
vont si j'avais la réponse on
organiserait pas le 12 juin cette
assemblée plénière et puis on a aussi
ouvert tout un groupe de travail pour
essayer de comprendre
alors il ya plusieurs à rexam oui il ya
sûrement un point lié à l'habitat
à 50 ans il n'y a pas eu historiquement
c'était la ville de la famille et donc
on n'a pas conçu saint quentin pour des
des petits foyers et il n'y a pas assez
de deux studios et deux pièces d'une
part et encore moins qu'en studio quand
on parlait de saint-quentin même où
parlait de moi je suis président ça
c'est un autre sujet j'essaie de
représenter l'identité saint-quentinoise
et je ne suis pas le représentant de
montigny de guyancourt où est somme
toute les problèmes avec l'ensemble du
territoire lance en territoire donc il
ya une difficulté qui est qui et des
eaux fait que cette tranche qui au
surplus se vit de manière commune de
plus en plus tard donc on est de plus en
plus célibataire jusqu'à 30 ans donc on
cherche des studios ont servi de pièce
et il y en a pas donc ça c'est un
premier sujet deuxième sujet c'est aussi
un problème de mobilité
parce que à saint quentin si vous lisiez
y revenir après avoir il ya tout entière
de saint quentin et ailleurs enfin
parfois on a envie d'aller à paris
et s'ils voulaient revenir de paris vers
23 heures ça peut devenir un sujet pour
le lendemain matin
et puis et puis il ya une troisième
difficulté qui qu'il y ait justement au
manque de vie sociale à
saint-quentin-en-yvelines si vous vous
promenez à 21h50 un ça déclenche pas une
hilarité absolue et vous avez quand même
par hasard la possibilité de rencontrer
un copain mais c'est vraiment un gros
alors apparemment du côté de derrière
l'estaca oui à côté du quartier pas du
lac est donc en effet
il ya plusieurs résidences étudiantes
ont été construites en même temps que
l'estac a ouvert en septembre 2015
quasiment en même temps plusieurs
résidences étudiantes côté du vélodrome
et puis également la place plutôt là ça
commence à vivre donc alors on se met en
place progressivement c'est c'est tout
récent et les sessions de sortu cocon
familial finalement qui sont en première
ou deuxième année souvent vont dans ces
résidences et il ya quelques
établissements de bars brasseries sont
verts ils emplissent par un peu
d'ambiance n'y avait rien d'autre
donc ça m'aiderait vient avec cet
événement vous riez mais c'est vrai mais
c'est est ce que ça veut dire deux alors
là on est dans un lieu particulier qui
quand même ce qu'on appelle la ville de
france qu'on a appelé la ville nouvelle
est ce que avec le recul
penser que cette finale sont des
réussites est ce que le côté jeu c'est
pas humain qu'on a dans les villes on le
retrouve dans ses constructions vous ce
que c'est resté un petit peu quand même
quelque chose d'anonymes et de compliqué
à vivre
je pense que l analyse par dont 50 ans
d'abord comme sa campagne se dérouler
cac total cinq villes nouvelles d'île de
france et de très loin
oui c'est la plus grande réussite il ya
une belle brochette steyn théâtre il ya
vraiment tous mes saint quentin a été
conçu comme d'ailleurs c'était le logo
de saint-quentin savez c'est le vert et
bleu avec cap tête les deux parents les
deux enfants saint-quentin c'était de la
ville familiale de jeunes ménages et
familial et donc tout le monde y
trouvait son compte sauf que les gamins
si je puis dire qu'ils sont nés à la fin
des années 70 début 80
en 2000 il avait passé le bac il
trouvait parfois à l'université mais
parfois pas et puis ils se trouvent et
surtout rien à faire de manière
conviviale donc ils sont partis et il
sait ce passage de la ville nouvelle à
une sorte de nouvelle ville qui qu'il
faut probablement voilà m hand parce
qu'il ya tout à 50 ans il ya de l'emploi
c'est le deuxième pôle économique de
l'île de france c'est quand même
extraordinaire
il y à de l'habitat avec l'effet baisse
que j'évoquais médias de l'habitat il ya
beaucoup de cultures pas bien connu
d'ailleurs on a trop mal connu il ya du
sport il ya de l'aviation il ya tout
sauf que il faut travailler faire en
sorte que la mayonnaise prenne bien des
étudiants à 17 milles
vous dites presque trop de cultures non
non je vais pas dire que j'ai dit
beaucoup de cultures donc peut-être un
peu essais mais il est pas bien c'est
une question qu'on peut se poser enfin
c'est vrai qu'il ya eu une sorte
d'utopie à la création des villes
nouvelles en dix ans la culture servir
de lien social or c'était un petit peu
l'idée il ya beaucoup beaucoup mieux
culturel est ce que est ce que ça se
justifie je sais peut-être difficile
avoue ne répond pas mieux mais est ce
que c'est vrai que est-ce qu'on justifie
aujourd'hui le fait qu' autour de lieux
culturels ou est ce que pour y avoir une
sorte de centralisation et ça serait
assez bénéfique
je pense qu'il suffit de regarder la
fréquentation des différents lieux
culturels de l'agglomération
ça fonctionne donc je pense pas qu'il ya
trop de culture après on s'entend les
uns des autres
l'espace marché de plats se marcher sur
les pieds on a chacun nos spécificités
je pense que c'est marrant parce que il
faut chez parler des 18-30 ans c'est
effectivement dans les théâtres la
tranche qu'il est très compliqué de
qu'il est très compliqué de touche deux
touches est bon mais c'est moi j'ai une
petite chose mais après j'ai une réponse
et il a esquissé cette réponse là c'est
la question des lieux de vie et c'est
aussi toutes les questions que doivent
se poser les théâtres lorsqu'on parle
des villes nouvelles
dans quasiment toutes les villes
nouvelles il ya ce théâtre alors qu'ils
et architecturalement fait oui fait
différemment mais à saint quentin je
pense que la culture c'était quand même
il ya cet énorme bâtiment au bout de
l'avenue du centre que l'on voie d'
extrêmement loin qui est quand même
imposant pour ne pas dire nsemi danse tu
vois là je pense qu'à une question à se
poser sur ses bâtiments sur ce qui
représente aujourd'hui je pense qu'ils
ont encore une très grande force
symbolique pour beaucoup d'habitants
maintenant comment transformer ces
bâtiments intimidant en lieu à vivre
voilà ce que ça correspond à la société
actuelle jeudi à cesser ces structures
qui est tout à fait respectable et
souvent balle à mai mais est-ce qu'elle
correspond à l'idée de l'art de vivre
ensemble j'ai un élément de réponse
puisqu'on travaille sur justement les
éléments d'identité de saint quentin en
yvelines
on a fait des réunions spécifiquement là
dessus il ya quelques jours unanimement
il ya trois lieux qui reviennent dont le
théâtre de st
tout bon toutes générations qui
reviennent comme lieu comme cole
symbolique saint-quentin pas de montigny
pas de guyancourt pas de le théâtre de
50,3 parce que ce but qu on le fréquente
ou pas il est visible
absolument il est un symbole est là pour
vous êtes un symbole parce que souvent
et c'est assez humain je dire y'a
forcément se sait pas aller peut-être
les maires les élus ils sont de
guyancourt ils sont de mon tennis ont
deux voisins etc et donc il ya une sorte
de nationalisme de clocher si je peux
dire il ya deux mais il ya des choses
comme le théâtre le théâtre saint
quentin on dit pas assez
j'ai pas mis les syllabes il a montré du
favori personne ne dit peut-être de
monty tous parlent d'eux mêmes pour
l'université de versailles oui oui ça a
été le coup de génie des chaînes
derniers relents nadeau et c'est d'avoir
à coller à saint-quentin-en-yvelines
versa et mediaset versailles saint
quentin en yvelines
saint quentin en yvelines n'est pas n'a
pas encore le rayonnement mondial que
dont versailles peut se prévaloir et les
versailles saint quentin
voilà mais c'est maintenant ancrée dans
les moeurs bien sûr choisir vous
personnellement choisi de venir
s'installer sur ce territoire à la
guerre il ya probablement une question
de place d'emplacement est-ce que c'est
difficile a été diffusée de convaincre
avait des étudiants de venir ici
justement justement la question de place
elle était très importante parce qu'on
nous sommes juste à côté des gars non à
la gare de saint quentin et avec une
passerelle qui permet directement
d'aller de sortir des trains est d'aller
à l'école sans même passer par la gare
puisque la guerre en fait de l'autre
l'autre côté des des quais donc nous
notre explication on rappelle qu'il ya
trois lignes qui permettent de venir à
saint quentin depuis paris et donc ça
c'est un élément extrêmement intéressant
leur le site estaca s'appelle estacades
paris saclay voilà donc là aussi on en
reparle quand vous allez en parler aux
gens du rcd paris saclay et alors quand
on compare à paris saclay et la facilité
de venir aujourd'hui à saint quentin par
les transports en commun c'est les
étudiants extraordinaire fait plus court
et malheureusement le transport par les
50 ans sur les vingt dernières années
sa in a augmenté de 10 minutes 10
minutes on peut dire c'est rien mais dix
minutes sur une demi heure c'est pas
rien et vos étudiants ingénieurs dont
ils viennent de 12 de toute la france
ont également recrutement nationale 1
alors on a quand même une proportion
importante qui viennent de la région
parisienne 2002 france caisse car notre
site dans la gare nord un site dans
l'ouest plus loin puisque west quitte à
laval en mayenne inquiéter créant en
2003 quand il ya une quinzaine d'années
globalement on a comme un recours
nationales suivant des critères qui sont
nationaux d'un concours national et est
donc on a une grande partie une majorité
d'étudiants qui viennent à 51 50
voilà qui est de marseille le besoin de
laver le strasbourg et donc c'est
d'ailleurs ce qu'ont ce qui se passe en
ce moment puisque on commence à voir des
étudiants avec parcours suppl qui ont
leurs résultats qui s'inscrivent en
espérant qu'ils viennent là pour
découvrir saint quentin pouvoir ou la
leur fils leur fille pourrait loger donc
c'est en ce moment justement que des
écrans plats que je mange justement nous
non pardon parce que les études un vrai
problème à paris notamment pour trouver
un logement ou s'ils sont pas des sites
c'est compliqué et cher alors les
équipes qui arrivent à l'estaca donc ils
connaissent pas du tout en général
choisissent plutôt les résidences
étudiantes
d'accord ça ç'a vraiment été très bien à
la baisse il ya de la place aujourd'hui
on est en régime stabilisé trois ans
après l'ouverture de l'école et le quai
de la place assez rapidement quand même
les étudiants au bout d'une heure des
deux années ils disent que la résidence
étudiante final les miens c'est sa très
bonne et donc se mettent en colocation
donc c'est un autre mode de recherche
d'appartement donc là il trouve des
appartements ou alors ils vont à paris
c'est vrai que là plus on avance aussi
dans le cursus universitaire des
étudiants mois ils utilisent les
facilités qui ont été conçues
initialement comme les résidences
étudiantes à l'aillet il ya dans votre
école de construction automobile et
aéronautique
il ya aussi des entreprises importantes
qui sont ça a été aussi je pense un bien
sûr société un élément majeur donc on
est attaqué une école qui est spécialisé
donc dans les transports et donc on a la
chance à saint quentin avec guyancourt
donc avec l encours d'avoir carbus
d'avoir
le centre de renault on a quasiment un
écosystème en fait des entreprises qui
est très important et qui bien
spécialisés sur les mêmes des transports
je suppose que les entreprises ont vu
d'un bon oeil l'arrivée de votre wii
histoire de l'estaca est intéressant
parce que chacun est écrivain industriel
sac a été créé en 1925 par un industriel
et est donc pendant quasiment un siècle
les statues assez développée avec les
entreprises
ces arrêts sont les entreprises donc
l'état qui a été créé par un ingénieur
dans l'aéronautique qui avait compris
jusqu'à près juste après la fin de la
première guerre mondiale que le 21e
siècle d'être un siècle et souvenirs
pour l'aéronautique et toutes les
grandes entreprises
dassault airbus safran toutes les
entités 36 entreprises en fait on peut
accompagner ce développement et si les
stats tient aujourd'hui à cette taille
c'est cette renommée l'estaca vient
juste de rejoindre là c'est la réponse
la semaine dernière le réseau des 25
meilleures universités et écoles
européennes de la relative qui s'appelle
le réseau pegasus tout ce développement
on le doit à l'accompagnement des
entreprises aller à l'université est ce
que le montre prêt toujours un gros mot
c'est une légende entretenue chez pas
enfin bon non non non absolument pas
c'est pas un gros mot bien au contraire
et je vais faire
nous nous avons compris quand je dis
nous fins et la communauté universitaire
dans son ensemble c'est à dire les les
enseignants chercheurs les chercheurs et
les étudiants eux mêmes
tout ce que nous pouvions tirer de bons
d'un partenariat intelligent avec avec
les entreprises je n'ose pas vous dire
que nos diplômes sont formatés ans en
partenariat avec les entreprises mais
pas loin c'est à dire que lorsqu'il est
question de revoir les maquettes
d'enseignement notamment et surtout en
masters où il est question très souvent
et c'est une bonne chose de
professionnalisation mais quand je dis
professionnalisation ce n'est pas non
plus un gros mot pour nous mais je
n'oublie pas non plus que à l'université
on enseigne aussi des choses
fondamentales
oui un rôle il ya eu la moindre des
choses pour nous faculté droit par
exemple c'est d'être très au fait de ce
que peuvent être les besoins de
professions juridiques judiciaires etc
donc on a on a ça va au delà de
partenariats sont en contact permanent
évidemment nous ne le les professionnels
comme si nous ne luttons pas d'ailleurs
toujours tendance à dire les
professionnels 1 parlant des autres
viennent dispenser des heures
d'enseignement dont nous dans toutes nos
formations enfin bien sûr que tout cela
n'est pas les universitaires ne sont
plus ont-ils jamais été déjà enfermé
dans une tour d'ivoire sans contact avec
l'extérieur
quelle est la différence justement
aujourd'hui est ce qui est différent
encore entre les universités et les
grandes écoles
de mon point de vue oui oui cette
position parce que sous celui à répondre
à cette question exactement une semaine
une semaine on l'a reçu à l'estac a eu
une délégation étrangère fait un bond
puisque il faut que la semaine dernière
il y avait la coopération des 20e
anniversaire de création de l'université
sans de l'enseignement supérieur en
europe
la convention de bologne et donc on a
reçu
à midi c'est l'enseignement supérieur
avec sa sombre de recteur de la
biélorussie puisque l'europe c'est au
sens ancien supérieur c'est 40 plus que
40 pays et est donc l'attaché
d'ambassade la première édition qui m'a
dit la première question qui m'a posé
ses mains dit qu'il comprenait rien
parce qu'une grande école c'est vraiment
un truc franchouillard franco-français
et ai donc expliqué le bi différence
intrus dans l'université
bon alors c'est vous visiez bologne
c'était la création de l'europe donc au
sens large du terme de l'enseignement
supérieur et ça a été une réflexion à
partir du diplôme donc c'est la création
du système lmd donc avec nos diplômes
licence master doctorat et le diplôme
d'ingénieur qu'est ce que c'est comme
d'ingénieurs dans ce système de bologne
à une correspondance diplôme d'ingénieur
confère le grade de master mais il ya
une grosse différence et la façon dont
ce diplôme d'ingénieur et réglementée
vous pouvez pas ouvrir une école
et puis délivrer un diplôme d'ingénieur
il ya une instance qui là aussi est
française mais qui est en train de
développer de plus en plus en europe et
dans le monde dans ce modèle est en
train d'être copié qui s'appelle la cti
commission des titres d'ingénieur et qui
vérifie
granit la correspondance et puis le
niveau d'oxygène d'excellence de de la
qualité et cette instance elle a été
créée par nous en 1934
paris s'en est la particularité cette
instance est calée paritaire paritaire
dont il ya trente-deux membres
il ya seize représentants de
l'enseignement supérieur et 16
représentants d'entreprises et ça c'est
sans doute de 1934 est encore
aujourd'hui une différence importante
pour vous donner un chiffre
dans les enseignants qui interviennent
par exemple à l'estaca on a quasiment un
facteur 10 ans nombre d'enseignants
entre des enseignants qui sont vraiment
des enseignants à plein temps de l'école
et puis des enseignants qui viennent de
l'entreprise exactement moi je viens de
l'entreprise j'ai enseigné en tant que
vacataire pendant longtemps et je
rejoins le secteur de l'enseignement
supérieur ça reste me semble-t-il une
différence encore importante dans cette
différenciation entre universités et les
grandes écoles à la salle van mens sens
parce que vous disiez qu'il ya une
différence à votre ya des similitudes
certains certains domaines de
l'enseignement elle le droit la médecine
le le montre nous sommes d'ailleurs
jalouse et méchamment par certains
collègues qui comprennent mal les choses
on peut pas enseigner la médecine sans
la pratique est de mon point de vue on
ne peut pas bien enseigné le droit sans
le pratiquer ou l'avoir pratiqué donc
nous avons oui j'en suis parfaitement
qu'on voyait beaucoup d'ail et bout il
ya beaucoup dans ces endroits qui sont
des praticiens qui sont pas des
praticiens à temps complet mais comme
tout la fac 95 % de mes collègues j'ai
fait pendant dix ans des dossiers dans
un cabinet d'avocats sama face à va
énormément apporter quand je me suis
trouvé face aux étudiants eux sont les
premiers convaincus du fait que entre ce
que dit le droit au sens large et la
réalité il ya souvent un écart assez
important dont j'étais en mesure de leur
parler dans la mesure de mes
possibilités
donc il ya parfois quelques similitudes
la lettre est là dit faire la différence
enfin il ya de multiples différences des
différences qui sont structurantes
c'est-à-dire il ya une tradition de de
symbiose absolue entre la recherche et
l'enseignement l'université c'est par
excellence je ne dis pas qu'il ya pas de
recherche dans les écoles mais c'est par
excellence part dieu où le savoir se
fabrique est où le
j'allais dire il ya eu un contact direct
entre le producteur du savoir et le
consommateur n'ayant pas consommateur
fort heureusement mais seul le
bénéficiaire du savoir
donc le l'université c'est d'abord une
usine à savoir c'est là que c'est là que
le savoir se fait et c'est là qu'il est
enseigné à mesure qu'il se fait et ça
correspond d'ailleurs vous le disiez à
ce que sont les grands standards
internationaux
allez expliquer ce qu'est une école à
des collègues étrangers
je crois que vous avez raison une
spécificité française à l'étranger il
existe des écoles mais la plupart des
écoles sont sous l'égide sont intégrés
sont des composants d'une université et
les choses changent
paris saclay en est un parfait exemple
ça change dans le bon sens
il ya cette différence là et puis il ya
des différences eu des différences
notables sur les conditions de
recrutement des enseignants chercheurs
sur les conditions de recrutement des et
nous ne choisissons pas nos étudiants en
première année
nous les choisissons ensuite nous les
sélectionnons je n'ai pas peur de le une
sélection qui est une véritable torture
cpt est une sélection marathon dont la
société se contente jusqu'à présent il
s'est contenté de cela c'est un choix
social qui de mon point de vue
extrêmement coûteux pas seulement en
argent mais aussi en énergie et puis
psychologiquement pour les étudiants
tome est coûteux pour la collectivité
aussi mais dont acte donc ce sont des
différences même très notable quand vous
voyez yahia alors c'est pas si
l'impression que tout cas la fin de vie
de droite pas été très atteinte par la
grève dès le jour les facs de droit sont
a pris part des parties moins connus de
86,2 les debré en général les facs de
droit sont les derniers parfois elles
contre réagissent oui il ya eu des
exemples
enfin je fais non non il n'ya pas aimer
ces blocages et ses mouvements mais mais
on était quand même ultra minorité mais
vous parliez de la sélection
disons toute façon elle existe un moment
ou un autre même s'il existe à les
sauver voilà 70 permanents
là on sent quand même mais c'est
toujours ça il ya quand même une sorte
de d'interrogation dire de malaise c'est
un mot qu'on en voit trop souvent mais
l'interrogation de la jeunesse sur son
propre avenir avec un monde
on voit bien que c'est là on a un monde
on va peut-être parler lionel masse et à
vous aviez organisé d'aider des
rencontres formidables ou entre la
culture est justement et les
problématiques danse artificielle du
transhumanisme enfin il ya quelques
temps on voit bien qu'on est dans un
monde qui va qui est en train de changer
comme il n'a peut-être jamais changé
comment vous comprenez comment vous
analysez peut-être le malaise est un bon
j'aime pas boire un certain malaise de
la jeunesse d'installer enfin c'est
presque puisqu'il est consubstantielle à
la jeunesse c'est ce que je vais vous
dire que c'est l'interrogation
aujourd'hui les jeunes sont et je vous
le confirme
y compris à l'université l'action
stressé sont inquiets j'ai trop entendu
parler ces derniers temps de
l'université comme d'un endroit cool sic
je cite un élu un grand élu national qui
disait bon il ya d'un côté les voies
sélective choisi à 60% par les sur
parcours su parler par les lycéens
futurs bacheliers puis les 42% qui vont
dans des endroits cool les amphithéâtres
des universités j'inviterais volontiers
ce grand élu venir constater que
graincourt nous empruntons ce ne sont
pas des endroits que je suis pro ceci
vous enseignez l'exemple
m'occuper un peu de la fondation qui
vous est présenté jusqu'à si sûr qu'il
ya un vrai malaise des étudiants et de
cette jeunesse en tant que tel est
effectivement suspects en substantielle
ou fait que quand on a 20 ans on
s'interroge parce que si on s'interroge
pas cet âge là c'est un peu préoccupant
mais je pense que ce qui les préoccupe
ses soutes surtout l'héritage qu'on va
leur léguer c'est ça qui les inquiète
parce que nous on a transféré notre
stress sur la retraite sur la couverture
sociale sur sûr et ils se disent mais
bon il va falloir qu'on paye pour tout
ça ce monde d'avant qu'on représente un
peu même si on est resté très très jeune
et est ce qu'on va pouvoir vivre en
supplie qu'est ce qu'on va devenir nous
non mais ils ont préféré intégrer que y
aurait pas de retrait
on leur laisse une petite plaie par
contre ils ont intégré aussi est pourvu
qu'ils aient envie de payer longtemps qu
il allait voir nous payer nos retraites
pendant donc il n'y a pas jeudi ils sont
ils sont intégrés dans les nouvelles
technologies intégrées dans le monde
actuel et je trouve pas plus stressé que
ça au fond mais stressé par l'héritage
qu'ils payent stress commence bien avant
l'université les codes mais je pense
belgique l'écho dès l'école élémentaire
il ya ce sentiment de deux sélections de
compétitivité voire de compétition qui
est inhérent je pense à toute une toute
une nouvelle génération donc d'y arriver
là d'université ou dans les grandes
écoles avec ce sentiment là mais ils
l'ont très proche de très proche de moi
ils l'ont des dés l'école élémentaire
à moins que ce soit les parents qui leur
transmettent ce stress là c'est
peut-être sociale et les services
algériens vous parlait il faut cher
transmis l'idée que la ville n'était pas
facile c'est vrai et en plus ce qui
n'était pas le cas d' peut-être deux
de votre de notre fédération enfin sur
les espoirs et celle d'avant et oui dix
allers les 30 glorieuses
moi je suis de la fin des trente
glorieuses
c'est vrai je vais rentrer à
l'université ce dans les années 70
c'était un sujet on aller là où on avait
envie d'aller commencé à dire attention
et là on parle des privilégiés pardonnez
moi parce que l'on parle de ceux qui
rentrent et le vrai sujet il est pas là
il est en dessous et on parlait de
formation d'intelligence le 21e siècle
s'il n'est pas le siècle de la
connaissance de siècle du savoir et bien
avant l'université
là ça va mal se passer parce qu'on ne
pourra pas laisser sur le bord du chemin
toute cette partie de la jeunesse qui
sent quasiment sans formation parce que
demain si on n'a pas un minimum de
formation je sais pas quel job on pourra
faire et on voit bien veillant dans les
statistiques fin que des cas une
formation l'accès à leur progression
bien plus facile en france on considère
que la formation c'est avant 20 ans tout
se joue avant 20 ans et donc c'est vrai
qu'aujourd'hui on a des jeunes qui
sortent qui n'ont pas la chance de faire
des études et dès qu'ils sortent du
système universitaire du système
d'enseignement 101-101 diplôme
d'enseignement supérieur dont on voit
quand même beaucoup d'enthousiasmé dans
dans les jeunes et dans une évolution
liée sans doute à l'évolution des
technologies ou ce qui se joue au moins
du diplôme initial l'année plus qui va
se jouer pendant toute la vie ça on
pense aussi que la formation tout au
long de la vie on est en train de monter
à l'estacade un nouveau diplôme qui sera
pas que c'est le dz quant au diplôme
d'ingénieur ou d'ingénieurs qui va se
spécialiser qui sera un nouveau diplôme
sur les systèmes et les véhicules
intelligents et qui sera dédié à des
personnes qui sont déjà en poste et qui
ont déjà de l'expérience professionnelle
et on peut devenir ingénieur à 35 ans 40
ans 50 ans il ya certainement là aussi à
concevoir de façon différente la
formation tout se joue plus avant 20 ans
alors bien sûr là toujours des enjeux
importants 1 et celui qui part qui rit
jaune important avec un diplôme de
grande école part avec un certain
avantage
mais tout se joue plus les écoles aussi
à réfléchir en lien avec l'ensemble du
système éducatif avec les entreprises
pour faire évoluer cette façon de voir
l'enseignement à dire on peut aussi à 30
ans reprendre des études intervient tant
un diplôme d'ingénieur nous c'est ce
qu'on propose c'est pas ça chez dior
c'est pas des structures sont pas bien
fait pour ça
jusqu'ici non trouvait pas sur toute
information et c'est ça devient enfin
oui beaucoup plus vous avez ce que ce
que ce que ce que dit pascal et milos et
de remise en cause de votre savoir
enfin ça vaut mieux parce que ne serait
ce que par non mais c'est vrai que c'est
vrai qu'à on a connu des enseignants qui
avaient trois heures de cours par
semaine qui avait fait recours
ce n'était pas le bon vieux temps
patrice vous savez la charge incombant
aux professeurs des universités était
équivalente à traves en 1979 et à trois
heures par semaine sur six mois par an
mais au moins les violets qu'il y avait
des livres et des gens qui travaillent
beaucoup il y avait des gens qui
travaillent à bout il ya des gens qui
écrit avec publié remise en cause oui
remise en précieuse dans ce jeu dire ce
que on comprend que dans les voitures
intelligentes etc
tout tout tout est remis en cause mais
est ce que dans le droit par exemple le
droit des voitures intelligentes
par exemple on a en un laboratoire nos
collègues privatiste le laboratoire
dante qui ce qui est notamment
spécialisé dans cette question la
question de la responsabilité si donc il
ya eu lieu et c'est tout ça le droit
doit essayer autant qu'il le peut de
suivre les choses et les juristes et les
professeurs de droit doivent essayer
aussi de s'accrocher à ce à ce mouvement
qui est un mouvement perpétuel ça je lis
chaque matin le journal officiel avait
une certaine parts angoisse je regarde
aussi le plus et le mieux que je peux la
la production jurisprudentielle des
juridictions suprêmes de ce pays et il
m'arrive
il m'arrive de m'apercevoir que quinze
jours trois semaines plus tôt j'ai dit
des bêtises aux étudiants parce que la
règle avait changé je le savais pas il
faut essayer de cette manque ça c'est
une règle imposée
et puis à des remises en cause ou des
dés et c'est bon je pens a plutôt des
expériences sur la manière d'enseigner
dans un amphi de première année par les
voir à notre enseigne à mener ou même en
doctorat on n'enseigne plus exactement
aujourd'hui quand vous le faisait il ya
quelques années même endroit même les
juristes se met qui sont plutôt
conservateurs se mettent à essayer de
nouvelles formules d'enseignement je
pense à la pédagogie inversée je pense
aux enseignements liés ni puis au
regroupement présentiel c'était avant
notamment en formation continue on a
beaucoup on expérimente beaucoup ce
genre de deux modalités d'un nouvel le
sont de moins en moins parce que je
disais sur les voitures autonomes on dit
souvent dire que le problème des
voitures autonomes c'est pas de les
fabricants c'est tout à fait les faits
c'est plutôt les juridique et saufs
compliqué à trouver de responsabilité et
sérieux on le monde est sur une
évolution de rupture un donc c'est pas
uniquement de la technologie là on est
vraiment sur une autre façon d'utiliser
un moyen de mobilité et donc avec des
questions oui juridique plein d'éléments
qui vont avoir une séquence 1 sur le sur
la société j'entendais ce matin un
impact sur justement les enjeux
médiatiques et donc en comparant la
télévision et la radio
donc ici on est un studio de télé et la
télévision et la radio finalement a
survécu à la télé lorsque la radio il
mangera vieux voilà il ya la question
qui était posée c'était est ce que la
radio va survivre à la vie que vous
véhiculez ottoman et et le discours
était oui le véhicule auto 28 pas tuer
la radio pourquoi parce que aujourd'hui
40% des personnes des auditeurs en fait
qu'ils écoutent la radio l'écoutant
voiture pourquoi de l'époque en voiture
parce que ils sont avec leur autoradio
et puis en même temps ils sont un peu
concentré quand même dans ce véhicule
autonome il faut autre chose
ils peuvent regarder ils peuvent être
sur google ça c'est une question s'est
imaginé pas à quatre classes
conséquences ap
il n'y a pas que l'aspect juridique
cohérent sur la résolution qui va dont
les conséquences vont est-ce que c'est
renault qui a pris des parts dans un qui
a racheté un quotidien ou dans un groupe
de presse anp à les concevoir une
nouvelle année de justement de
programmation du théâtre de saint
quentin vous dites je ne sais rien oui
parce qu'en fait on est on est toujours
en recherche que j'ai tout à dire c'est
qu'on est des 100 de têtes chercheuses
ont donc comment est-ce que le le le
spectacle attentif aux évolutions
ouais spectacle quand même beaucoup de
choses 200 hectares par saison chacun
des trois affaires la programmation donc
on est attentif et puis on voit ces
évolutions vous parler de deux
technologies
effectivement les nouvelles technologies
le théâtre les arts de la scène s'en
sont emparés depuis longtemps en fait je
crois qu'il ya toujours eu une un
cousinage entre entre les arts de la
scène et les nouvelles technologies mais
c'est un cousinage qui date de quand il
est même souvent la culture sans les
choses avant avant même qu'on les
quelques les autres acteurs de la
société les formules non mais comme
souvent elle précède souvent
et puis lille est pas rare que de
développeurs fassent appel à des
artistes pour tester certaines
fonctionnalités pour imaginer les
artistes pour imaginer des
fonctionnalités que ok le même nom n'ont
pas pensé donc la technologie alors ceux
qui évoluent avec les nouvelles
technologies aujourd'hui c'est la place
du technicien
il ya encore il ya encore 15 ans 20 ans
les techniciens ce qu'imaginaient les
spectacles pouvait le faire seul
enfermés dans leur dans leur chambre ou
dans leur studio c'était des musiciens
et puis après quand vous avez besoin de
le traduire
il faisait appel était technicien
aujourd'hui la complexification des
technologies est tel que l'artiste le
créateur le concepteur a besoin dès le
départ d'avoir un super technicien ou un
technicien créateurs qui lui même va lui
faire un retour sur les possibles et
dont va nourrir son imagination et sa
capacité à concevoir des objets ça c'est
une vraie révolution c'est pas les accès
à la technologie nation en 1969 lorsque
les corses que pink floyd utilise le
mook nouveau synthétiseur
c'est un truc extraordinaire mais ils
sont des gendres dans l'été une
technologie aujourd'hui c'est que
artistes et super techniciens
travaillent ensemble la création et plus
et plus collectif donc on essaie aussi
d'être attentif à ça fait la
programmation
pour moi la technologie dans le
spectacle est un non sujet dans la
mesure où elle intègre le spectacle à
intégrer la technologie au fur et à
mesure voilà donc il n'y aurait pas une
case
même si aujourd'hui la tendance est la
tendance à dire des cases spectable et
nouvelles technologies
c'est inhérent au spectacle c'est de
faire de faire de travailler ensemble
une sorte d'artisanat de la scène et de
technologies de pointe
alors vous allez présenter le programme
de la nouvelle saison le 5 juin prochain
mais peut-être en avant première on peut
prévoir un petit sujet avec quelques uns
des spectacles qu'on verra au cours de
la saison prochaine que vous en êtes
amoureux près
[Musique]
j'ai travaillé pendant deux ans en
immersion on rencontre deux jeunes
femmes en leur prenant des questions
qu'elle était capable de me livrer de
2,7 choses intimes en elle et de la
partager ensuite avec le les spectateurs
[Musique]
et quelques spectacles c'est un petit à
petit bastos et je veux dire ma voix ils
sont bel et bien aux autres ce qu'on a
vu ce qu'on a vu c'est quelque chose est
représentatif de ce qui est de ce qu'est
la saison à savoir un théâtre en fait
quand on conçoit une saison on doit
aussi tenir compte de l'outil dont on
dispose il se trouve que de tête de
saint quentin
l'outil c'est d'abord une scène qui fait
600 m² avec une ouverture qui à peu près
la même que celle de l'opéra bastille
une salle des mille mille et quelques
places à côté de ça une petite salle de
300 places
donc on travaille avec ces deux outils
là pour à la fois travailler sur des
grands formats plutôt populaire sur des
artistes assez repérer c'est à dire des
stars mais des stars dans le spectacle
vivant sont pas forcément connus du
grand public
et puis sur sur un repérage de jeunes de
jeunes artistes émergents
donc ce qu'on a vu là c'est à la fois
c'est ce mélange de qu'on essaye
d'arriver à équilibrer entre
l'expérimentation et puis le populaire
et le grand spectacle
c'est notre travail avec une
programmation qui l'année prochaine ça
aussi ça fait partie des choses qui
évoluent sans même parfois quand s'en
aperçoive vous voyez on se dit tiens on
va pouvoir justifier tout le choix là
par exemple la saison prochaine il ya
chez pas la moitié mais un tiers des
artistes qui viennent de l'étranger
ouais voilà qui
ça va du cap vert aux états unis bon ben
mais c'est quelque chose de bon sens
mais on s'en est aperçu une fois que
c'était sur la une fois que s'étaient
fixés sur sur la plaquette là où on a
voulu agir en revanche c'est sur une
certaine parité
même si le tas de saint quentin était
pas forcément concernés par la question
de la parité était déjà attentifs à ça
et la question de la de rendre visible
l'invisible la diversité quand vous
dites la parité des spectacles la
présence et sa présence quasi
équivalente entre les hommes et les
femmes de votre émission absolument et
la diversité à l'image de votre émission
est égal
c'est à dire qu'il est important aussi
que cette diversité soit présente sur
les plateaux c'est à dire que moi je
gage que la diversité sur les plateaux
c'est à dire que sur les scènes de
théâtre sur les scènes des salles soient
représentés la société française telle
qu'elle est telle qu'elle est je pense
sur un gage que la salle soit aussi un
tout petit peu plus mixtes si le débat
au festival de cannes
on dit mais pourquoi il n'y a pas autant
de films de femmes quelques de films
d'hommes et le délégué général du
festival nava l'air de dire non non ce
qu'on regarde s'il suffit mais bien et
pas bien ou pas bien pas si ce sont des
hommes ou des femmes qui les font ouais
je pense que si on change de prismes et
si on change juste une autre façon de
regarder la question se pose tout à fait
différentes séries c'est à dire que je
la question la question de la de
regarder de regarder un objet artistique
pure et simple
en sachant dans tous les cas que se
nomme ou que c'est une femme qui l'a
fait en ne le regardera pas de la même
manière
donc comment regarder ces deux objets de
la même façon c'est là quand je dis
décaler le regard c'est arrivé à
intégrer que l'on doit regarder ces deux
objets artistiques de la même façon
aujourd'hui je pense qu'on a on a un
regard qui est biaisé alors petit à
petit cela ça évolue très vite
depuis deux ans trois ans oui je vous
lis tes rides et c'est tant mieux c'est
je pense que là le fait d'arriver sur
beaucoup de scènes de théâtre à la
parité n'a pas fait baisser la
l'exigence artistique des programmateurs
voilà moi je suis persuadé grèce 2-0
mais alors vous dites depuis deux trois
ans on y arrive assez facilement qu'on
l'a trouvé au fond des spectacles fait
par des artistes femmes autant que par
des artistes sur la diversité compris
quelque chose c'est une question de
s'autoriser à partir du moment où il ya
des créateurs des créatrices qui
s'autorisent à elles sont présentes et
pour la diversité c'est exactement la
même chose c'est une question de
légitimité d'intégrer sa légitimité à
être sur un plateau de théâtre ça ne va
pas plus loin
à part que ça prend du temps pour que
l'on pour que l'on y arrive simple et
les spectateurs pour eux c'est la même
chose il n'y a pas de dégâts pas de
réaction il n'y a pas de
non non non hélas pourquoi pourquoi non
pour l'instant il n'a pas eu je sais pas
[Rires]
vous mais voilà il ya bal avec et fouché
la difficulté c'est en effet une
certaine tranche d'âge de l'amener vers
l'est que dure notamment dans le théâtre
écoutez moi quand j'étais étudiant en
droit public à l'université de pau je
préférais très large expérience
universitaire ville
j'avais c'est vrai qu'il ya 18 ans
j'avais plus envie d'aller d'aller boire
d'aleppo petite halle pierre légère avec
avec des amis plutôt que d'aller au
théâtre lors ya peu théâtre à pau à
l'époque mais non mais je pense que
quelques enjeux quand je disais que
fastidieux c'est la wii est vrai
festival officiel qui que dit que dirige
érogènes moi j'ai le souvenir ça mais
quand je dis que les mêlées on et
comment comment est-ce que d'aider des
jeunes moi le terme de jeunes déjà mais
est un terme que je comprends pas at il
de commun entre un jeune qui est dans un
établissement privé parisien avec 100 %
de réussite au bac est bon donc on va
dire entre 18 et 30 ans on à ce besoin
de liberté là nous des jeunes et jeunes
entre 4 et 18 ans ils sont là et dans
une grande dans une grande diversité de
milieux culturels sociaux ils sont
vraiment présent dans les écoles dans
l'est c'est pas des efforts c'est notre
travail notre avance hamayde de créer
c'est de créer des référents commun
comment ces jeunes qui sont tellement
différents qui viennent de milieux
tellement différente on est 100
d'intérêt tellement différent
peuvent-ils et qui ont accès à tous
grâce à une connexion peuvent-ils avoir
des référents commun ou des réflexions
sur des oeuvres communes c'est-à-dire
concret du
on essaie de créer du commun c'est ça le
travail de théâtre après 18 ans on se
rend compte que les grands adolescents
les jeunes adultes vont au théâtre qui
ont une culture familiale qui les a
acquises à aider à ça après la question
que doivent se poser les théâtres et que
j'ai skié tout à l'heure c'était comment
peuvent-ils devenir des lieux de vie
c'est à dire que je pense qu'un théâtre
aujourd'hui ne doit plus être cette
institution intimidante devenir reine à
acquérir une culture légitime mais ça
doit être un lieu d'expérience comment
concurrencer la connexion qui permet
d'accéder à tous c'est en étant les en
étant les lieux d'une expérience
alors c'est la connexion la connexion
numérique dans la mesure on doit pouvoir
fréquenter un thé à travailler dans un
théâtre en buvant un café ou une boisson
une boisson gazeuse saturant sucre
l'après midi on doit pouvoir y rejoindre
ses amis donc ça c'est l'expérience
collective la la connexion la connexion
aux autres pour boire un verre avant le
spectacle pour manger un morceau
et si ensuite il ya la connexion à
l'intimé la collection un soin qui le
temps de la représentation et le temps
de la représentation
c'est quelque chose auquel je tiens
particulièrement parce que c'est le
temps où l'on va se connecter à ce qui
se passe on va écouter où on va être
dans un respect des autres de ceux qui
sont autour de nous on va aussi se
connecter à soi comment est ce qu'on
reçoit intimement une oeuvre qui sur
scène donc c'est cet ensemble
d'expériences cette succession
d'expériences que doit proposer un
théâtre et on peut même après leur
représentation finir en soirée électro
jusqu'à 2h 3h du matin voilà les
théâtres ce vers quoi ils doivent tendre
comment est-ce qu'on encadre la
découverte d'une oeuvre artistique scène
publique nationale peut-être peut-être
des poids plus compliqué à déplacer mais
il ya beaucoup de théâtre aujourd'hui
qu'ils vivent toute la journée
mais nous on vient on vit le théâtre de
tas de 50 ans alors il est ouvert
la journée appréciée d'autres
interrogations qui se pose comme un
style devient ce lieu de vie comment les
étudiants de l'estaca peuvent en soirée
à 17h 18h venir boire un verre comment
ils peuvent à 22h quand ils ont fini
travail est de faire leur travail pour
le lendemain venir boire un verre dans
le théâtre sans forcément assister à une
représentation même si moi mon travail
et l'équipe du théâtre c'est de les
amener à se découvrir un objet un objet
artistique parce que la connexion c'est
super mais je pense qu'être être en
présence directe de respectivement d'une
oeuvre juste devant soi ça change
absolument tout l'expérience et fort
fort différente parce qu'un bilan juste
avant la présence de la culture c'est
important pour vous étudiants aussi bien
sûr c'est très important on dit non à
une sélection sur les mathématiques mais
on dit quelqu'un qui a 5 ans
d'expérience des mathématiques il en
fait plus que par courante aussi c'est
qu'il est sa capacité à à comprendre le
monde sa capacité à parler français tout
simplement à s'exprimer c'est ça
finalement qui fera son évolution dans
ton parcours
moi j'ai bien aimé ce que vous avez dit
sur la collectivité parce que je pense
que ce qui est difficile où l' on le
voit dans les courses et des spectateurs
je suis spectateur je veux spectacle et
ça ça fonctionne plus et est donc il
faut de l'interactivité il faut être
acteur leur être acteur c'est pas le
vêtement et sur la selle mais voilà
c'est savoir avant avant la
représentation après leur présentation
et est même arrivé en faisant des
oeuvres et avoir une interactivité et ça
c'est important pour que
spectateurs à l'ancienne ne soit pas
complètement sainte
oui mais je pense que c'est une pratique
être spectateur c'est à la fois être
disponible et vigilants donc cet être
être actif d'une certaine façon les
spectateurs actifry ça peut exister
ça devait exister quand vous entendez ça
c'est plutôt rassurant séparation c'est
enthousiasmant
je pense qu'il nous faut beaucoup de
lionel bah c'est un 50 ans et demi parce
que je pense qu'il ya effectivement
beaucoup de lieux de vie de culture mais
pas qu'eux qui n'attend que d'être
ouvert et disponible parce que c'est
comme ça que le manque de vie sociale
liée vous fait que saint quentin c'est
un territoire gigantesque on dit je vais
à côté et on s'est tellement à côté
qu'on n'y va jamais autrement qu'en
voiture
donc ce jeune homme est quasiment et
donc pour essayer de donner de la vie à
tout ça il faut des lieux de vie je
disais tout à l'heure je n'avais pas
entendu
lionel que que le théâtre de saint
quentin est un emblème de ce territoire
et ben si au surplus et je suis prêt dé
lionel à 200 là dedans ça devient un
lieu de vie complètement ses magnifiques
parce que parce que ce qu'attendent les
jeunes ce qu'ils demandent c'est aussi
ça c'est de la vie alors après c'est la
poule et l'oeuf qui est ce qui fait de
livrer ce qu'il faut les faire rentrer
de théâtre mais les cerner les mots
magiques c'est peut-être ses impressions
tels que c'est
telle quelle architecture la batterie
mais mais c'est en débat mais ces sujets
qui font débat avec avec l'agglomération
de saint quentin mais c'est vrai que moi
je suis pas mal sur le territoire qu'ils
soient en france ou ailleurs
et quand on voit ddd théâtre avec 90% de
deux jeunes gens entre 16 et 25 ans et
plutôt enthousiasmant on se demande
comment faire venir les vieux non non
non j'ai voulu des étudiants disent
qu'ils avaient vu celui de l'an dernier
j'ai vu celui de cette année sont
fascinés par le changement la rapidité
du changement quand même comment
justement vous disiez voilà on peut plus
à prendre comme on apprenait puisqu'on a
appris une fois que vous voulez a pris
c'est tout de suite dépassé
comment qu'on fait avec ça avec cette
réalité là cette accélération
cette accélération ceux d'essence du
temps et dans votre domaine des
transports il ya toujours eu lieu oui
qu'en mai bc avoir dealé commence
peut-être plus rapide encore enfin le
c'est toujours difficile sur le moment
de donner des détails sur la vague des
ce2 dans le transport comme
20e siècle avec l'automobile et
l'aéronautique et évolutions en
transport et la mobilité
donc aujourd'hui les nouvelles
technologies donc elles vont allier dans
l'ensemble de la société rapport de
cédric villani fait qu'ils ont identifié
quatre domaines où souvent
l'intelligence artificielle et les
nouvelles technologies doivent être
traitées de façon prioritaire en france
et il ya les transports et de mobilité
donc nous on voit que encore une fois
l'ingénieur c'est quelqu'un qui à partir
de la technologie et sa connaissance
technique apporte des réponses aux
enjeux de la société donc la voiture
électrique pourquoi on réfléchit
aujourd'hui à la voiture électrique
parce qu'il ya des enjeux le but contre
la chaux-de-fonds climatique et des
énergies une vision de le dire pour dire
je sais pas la voiture électrique sera
prépondérante dans en même temps alors
après chacun doit battre ça va quand
même lentement
ça va quand même lentement et
aujourd'hui on est plutôt sur
l'hybridation des sources bref vous avez
une voiture électrique pour qu'elles
polluent pas en vivre et puis
or là donc hors essence il voulait faire
des longs trajets donc ceci vase
maintenant où j'étais en chine avec
rencontre avec universités en chine
qu'il ya d'autres façons de gérer le
pays et ils ont décidé à pékin plus haut
qu'un deux roues à moteur thermique et
quand vous allez maintenant à pékin
voyez plus un seul des roues avec un
moteur à explosion
bon donc je pense que c'est quand même
ça ça va prendre du temps il ya des
enjeux de l'infrastructure donc ça va
prendre du temps ça va prendre du temps
donc on parle oui il faut aujourd'hui
vous pouvez acheter une sauvage était
une voiture complètement électrique
il ya des problèmes de may a duré ce
jour la fondation qui veulent se
déplacer quand même un petit peu
écoutez bien merci merci infiniment à
tous les quatre se rappelle alors lionel
messi talent de 5 juin au théâtre vous
présenter le programme de l'année
prochaine puis ce sera retransmis sur tv
78 le 12 juin 12
le coc d'esquire ouvert à tous dans tout
cinquante invités et au delà pour
discuter de de ce que cette tranche
d'âge que tout le monde cherche veut
pour réussir et être heureux et vivre et
travailler à 50 ans et ceux qui veulent
voir si la vie de professeur et simple
à juste et rigoureuse et stéphane amati
fichiers je suis comme tout défaut que
bientôt je veux les voir les étudiants
merci merci à philippe à tous les clubs
très bientôt
[Musique]